the forest of the fallen Giants the last
episode of story mode focused on Hyde's
Tower of flame and the origins of that
place in this episode we explore the
forest of the fallen Giants and this
place gives us a bit more of an
understanding about the world and our
place within it we are undead our body
is rotting and our mind is
disintegrating we came here to cure this
curse that was our purpose the curse is
a part of life itself no one will ever
be rid of it but as we travel through
the land we discover that drangleic is
the land of lost purpose many Undead you
might actually forget why they're there
and you aren't any exception to this
rule a journey has only just begun and
we're already being introduced to new
goals goals that aren't our own are you
the next monarch or merely a pawn of
fate we came here to cure the curse and
maybe finding the king will give us
answers but we don't know whether
they're going to be the ones we seek
it's not strange given her dialogue that
we're instantly drawn to trust her
bearer of the curse I will always be at
your side until hope has fully withered
the Emerald Herald gives us the
direction and the tools we need to
progress in the world she asks for
nothing in return
yet she pushes us in a very singular
direction go on and see the king he who
made rang like what it once was he who
peered at the essence of the soul King
vendrick beyond the bonfire lies the
forest of the Giants where a great
battle precipitated the kingdom's down
for the Warriors who fell there still
cuts their swords you need not be afraid
for the battle is done the combatants
freed forever and so we travel to the
forests of the fallen Giants and maybe
just maybe we can hope to discover what
has happened in this land we decide to
seek the king and discover the story
behind the war-torn land he left behind
simply push to uncover the story of the
world we find ourselves in and those are
our goals right now and yet you can't
quite shake the feeling that you didn't
quite come here to become a monarch you
came here to cure the curse and yet it
feels like you're serving somebody
else's purpose once again regardless we
seek the king and we start in a forest
where his war took place long ago the
forest has grown around a rundown fort
that was severely damaged during the
Kings war with the Giants the first
enemies we encounter are the hollow
infantry clearly low-ranking soldiers
who were tasked with defending the art
skirts of the fort and it's clear that
they hollowed long ago from the rundown
look of their equipment but even now
even though their hollowed they still
defend the fort and clutch their weapons
as some muscle memory seems to exist
even when hollowed individually they're
very weak but they're really aggressive
and they'll attack you on sight and you
have to use that to your advantage you
try to fight them individually they have
very little combat sense we climb into a
structure that would once have been a
tower on the outskirt of the fort but
it's been eroded by nature and in the
center is a Haida Knight hade fell into
the sea long ago and it resembles the
land of anor londo and this is where
Guinevere the princess of the way of
wight watched over her subjects these
Knights are passive even while hollowed
they don't have this desire to attack
hollows seem to retain some basic
instinct from the person they once were
for example the infantry know how to use
their weapons and they continue to
defend the places they hollowed within
could it be then that this White Way
midnight also retains some sense of who
he was perhaps these white knights once
aided travelers or it might just not be
in their nature to cut them down when
provoked though he defends himself we
take him down with lightning because we
will put this Knights equipment to
better use than he will his lightning
sword scales with faith and it's going
to be our weapon for a while there are
some clues as to the origins of this
Knight and maybe you understand what I
kind of hinted at before there are other
white knights of hade within drangleic
and we'll have to discuss them again
when we go to them because they
definitely have a story we make our way
to the fort pass the royal soldiers in
the hollow infantry and inside we find
Merlin sure you stranger to this land or
we get to strangers these days
everybody's bullying run off drangleic
spin a pile of rubble since the boar
thought long long ago and the Giants
rushed to see seem like the battles
would never end it said that wherever a
giant fell in battle a tree grew in its
place we get this information from the
seed of the tree of giants and I quote
death is not the end for anything that
has ever once lived remains a part of
the great cycle of regeneration
one of the biggest themes in Dark Souls
2 his regeneration and rebirth this
theme is in the gameplay it's in the
setting and it's in the game's universe
as a whole keep the idea of rebirth in
mind as we progress and ask yourself is
this world dying or is it being reborn
oh yeah I forgot to mention before
coming to this area solo I decided to
summon a few white phantoms to test out
the online functionality and then this
happened this is why you keep fire bombs
in your inventory so good around here we
meet paté hello there
traveling all alone in these treacherous
times well I hope you have a very good
reason Oh hogwash Who am I to judge
my name is pate I journeyed here and
thither on a sort of treasure hunt you
might call it be careful out there
there's talk of unsavory bandits who
prey upon travelers like yourself oh yes
he'll be cautious if you go any farther
there's treasure in there for certain
but the entrance locks from behind I saw
the same design earlier and it's the
same contraption I'm sure I was with
this warrior you see and he insisted
that he go inside first the rather
brusque fellow tried to swipe the lid
for himself they trapped him inside I
still have the gents ring I do hope he
wasn't harmed I'll leave this one to you
I'm worried about what might be inside
well I see you managed to escape Oh take
this it allows undead to call out for
help to one another across the fissures
between worlds with luck
somebody will lend your hand he gives us
a white summon soapstone and we're going
to summon him for the next boss fight
because it's good to get help with
tricky patches in the game right this
also furthers his quest line and we're
going to see him later in the game if we
keep him alive during this fight we've
taken an elevator down to the depths of
the earth with the last giant lies long
ago the King sought out the Giants
across the sea he waged war with them
and then he returned and brought peace
to his kingdom but the peace was
short-lived just as the curse of the
undead was taking over his kingdom the
Giants came for revenge we know this
from events later in the game so I won't
elaborate for now but for now know that
this is supposedly the last giant in
drangleic and it hates you it hates you
so much that it will rip off its dead
arm just so it can reach you more
effectively and this hate could be
something to do with all the human
weapons thrust into it from all sides or
perhaps it's the iron shackles around
its feet and arms or perhaps it's
something else but we'll have to explore
more of the world before we can figure
that out
regardless you defend yourself and you
acquire the soul
of the last giant it tells you that the
giant was preparing for its final rest
and that despite this his soul remained
magnificent despite what it had been
through and there's another item later
in the game that talks about the
determination of these giants and how
they have this will that is unbreakable
so now that we have the soldiers key we
can open up all the lock doors in the
fort and eventually we make it outside
to these ruined ramparts the huge
statues here have crumbled and broken in
a long-forgotten war and here we
transition to our new game+ character
where we fight the pursuer the pursuer
according to his soul the creature hunts
down those branded by the curse of the
undead and that's as if every undead
soul that he claims will atone one of
his sins also according to the guide
he's carried by a crow even though I
think it looks like an eagle anyway this
is a symbol of sin related to the
goddess Velka and he gets a little bit
more than he bargained for with us you
can either take him out using these
nearby ballista or you can learn his
pattern and dodge his attacks quite
easily not much else is known about the
pursuer but we haven't seen the last of
him there are 10 things in the forest of
the Fallen Giants that you probably
missed and I'd love to see if you could
get all 10 the link on screen will take
you there but that does it for the story
within the forest of the fallen Giants
I'll see you guys next time
also I am currently running a campaign
to improve my videos and to be able to
afford better content and it's going
great
I've recently ordered a much better
microphone that will reduce all the
reverb and I've got better recording
equipment in general and the thing is
all the people who Kindle this channel
are responsible for some of the amazing
content that's going to appear on my
channel in the next year to learn more
about what it's about just click the
bonfire but regardless of whether you do
or not just thank you so much for
watching my videos I'll see you next
time